alors haut niveau lui parce que tu as
brûle et on passe non match alors je
vais le faire symbolique
vraiment pas parce que pour venir chose
cloche n'est obligé de faire des passes
et là je vous lance un message moi je
vous lance un message ça c'est la flamme
de la liberté j'espère qu'on va
retrouver nos libertés pour nous et nos
enfants vous voyez c'est symbolique mais
moi je le fais devant vous monsieur qui
grandit de
beaux messages s'est passé alors ce
serait bien de le retenir non mais bon
au lit vos livres pourquoi parle-t-on
pas en fait je n'arrive pas à comprendre
d'ailleurs je vous plains moi je vous
dis honnêtement je vous plains pas ce
que vous êtes en train de défendre
l'indéfendable regarder un petit peu ce
qui se passe dans notre pays étant mieux
l'erea se vide c'est génial on nous
apprend qu'il ya au micron qui est à 80
90 % moins sévère que le reste c'est
encore mieux les pays qui sont autour de
nous qui sont en train de lever les
restrictions l'espagne qui voudraient
passer ça comme une grippe l'israël nous
apprend aujourd'hui qui veulent arrêter
la quatrième dose enfin tout est en
train de se lever et vous vous continuez
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce que vous
voulez pas dire c'est que vous êtes en
train de faire impasse politique vous
allez ramené de la contrainte jusqu'au
bout et puis dans un mois ou deux je ne
sais pas moi je le sens venir comme ça
vous allez faire une levée des
restrictions ce qui amènera la notoriété
pour la personne que vous défendez
perpétuellement monsieur macron est
comme ça il aura une grosse remontée
dans les sondages c'est bien joué vous
êtes fort dans la communication mais
enfin là que ça se sache et moi
j'appelle tout le monde à retrouver sa
liberté hashtag boules tombent à soi
alors il va vous répondre à françois
jolivet dans un sens il est très calme
toujours
une tribune dans la loi je vais beaucoup
parler son titre l'obligation vaccinale
doit être notre cap
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce que vous
dit au niveau et après on va voir le
professeur christian perronne qu'on voit
plus dans les médias a une manière très
très humoristique syrie le choix temps
de dire à monsieur est ce qu'il ya un
problème sur plateau il fait trop chaud
je comprends pas ce que vous me dites
parce qu'en fait vous êtes sur une
indépendance stratégique pour vocation
c'est vrai je comprends pas grand chose
mais on pourra en parler et on est là
pour ça d'ailleurs ce que ce que je
voudrais simplement dire c'est que
moi j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui que la
politique du pass sanitaire est une
bonne chose puisque ça permet de sauver
des vies j'ai le sentiment que le pass
vaccinale qui s'est construit depuis
maintenant pas de 4 à 5 mois est aussi
une bonne chose parce que ça permet en
fait on oublie toujours les gens
disaient ils peuvent faire des tests
baissière et accéder dans les locaux
loués par contre il pouvait tout de même
attrapé la maladie parce que je sais on
sait tous que le pass sanitaires et même
le pass vaccinale n'empêche pas d'être
contagieux donc c'était fait pour
protéger les autres et moi j'en ai marre
que l'on restreint des libertés à des
gens comme moi qui suis vacciné qui a
d'ailleurs attrapé le co lead est
originaire ou non et qui attrape nigaud
mine mais qui a été vaccinée et en fait
je m'aperçois qu'en fait toute la
politique est faite pour protéger que
ceux qui ne le sont pas et donc avec eux
valérie petit et le maire de
fontainebleau ferry n'est que eh bien on
a décidé d'écrire cela parce qu'en fait
la politique vaccinale dans notre pays
est pas nouvelle et je rappellerai
d'ailleurs à tous ceux qui assistent à
ce débat et aux téléspectateurs que ans
le 31 décembre 2017 nous avons au
parlement votait dans une majorité sans
frontières
rendu obligatoire aux vaccins il y en
avait 3 avant huit ont été ajoutés on
n'a pas parlé d' attendant la pad x a
intenté aux libertés individuelles